we got to shake things up yep bring it  on this will be a first for the vocalist  what I'm trying to tell you is that he's  off his rocker  [Music]  I'm going home and filing charges I was  that was pretend rewinds like I think I  might need some direction yes you are  lost in world of divisions everybody's  got something they're hiding watch I  have a song playing over and over in my  head I just don't have the words of the  melody do you have anything sometimes  your inner voice wants to express itself  and every once in a while your song  comes out to play that's what I'm  talking about  [Applause]  give me something to hold on to  love you Troy  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you